Princess Diana was just 20 years old
when she married Prince Charles she
captured the hearts of people all over
the world and this summer marks the 20th
anniversary of her death tonight CBS
will air a two-hour special on the life
death and the legacy of the woman who
became known as the people's princess
this is a preview the world thought they
knew her twenty years later we finally
learn who she really was
her name was Diana and the world fell in
love with her but her fairytale life
also had heartache as you know it did
not have a happily ever after ending in
1981 the world was transfixed as Diana
Spencer made her way down the aisle of
st. Paul's Cathedral towards her prince
[Applause]
[Music]
sixteen years later all eyes would be on
a solemn procession towards Westminster
Abbey Princess Diana's sudden death left
the world in mourning and two young boys
without their mother well I think
Diana's death robbed the world of an
extraordinary luminous character Patrick
Jepsen was Diana's private secretary she
leaves an unfillable gap on the world
stage when history looks back at the
20th century there may be six style
icons Princess Diana is on that list
it's irrefutable
[Music]
yet Princess Diana was also accessible
and compassionate she visited and
touched AIDS patients at a time when
fear often overshadowed reason she went
on to leprosy the mentally ill the
homeless diana was the people's princess
but behind the public adulation there
was private turmoil royal biographer
Sally Bedell Smith says diana was
consumed by jealousy over Charles's
ex-girlfriend Camilla parker-bowles
this jealousy became a real canker in
the relationship very very early as a
marriage crumbled both sides began
affairs but the breaking point came in
1992 when a bombshell book was published
based on a secret recording diana had
made about her unhappy marriage bulimia
and even a suicide attempt Ingrid Seward
is the editor in chief of majesty
magazine she immediately made enemies of
the royal family it was a true war
scandal after scandal would rock the
royal family by 1995 the palace had
finally had enough Princess Diana and
Prince Charles were divorced the
following year get the public's love
affair with Diana was far from over but
no one could have imagined that these
would be the last images anyone would
see of the princess alive
she died in the early morning hours of
August 31st 1997 after a car crash in a
Paris tunnel this gorgeous fairy
princess you don't expect her to end her
life in a traffic accident the
circumstances of Diana's death were
shrouded in mystery
conspiracy theories flourish tonight we
will put them to rest we will tell you
exactly what happened and finally get to
know the woman who showed the world that
power doesn't come from a crown
it comes from your heart now our
two-hour primetime special airs tonight
starting at 8 o'clock those times don't
remember that what did you learn in
putting this together you know the thing
that surprised me most Nora is that they
had only been out 12 times before they
got married I didn't know that Charlie
but I started working on this they had
only been together 12 times and at one
point Prince Philip pressured his son to
said look now you have to do the right
thing they wanted someone who was
virginal who seemed very innocent and
she certainly seemed to fit all those
categories if she was just 19 years old
she was just 19 when they met even
though he clearly he and Camilla
parker-bowles had a relationship and she
was not considered so virginal to to put
it diplomatically but I was fascinated
by that to know that and there was a 12
year age difference between the two of
them to anybody pointed one particular
party and blamed them for the break-up
or is it just simply the circumstances
of age and I think was and they didn't
really have anything in common when you
look at what he liked and what she liked
and there were a lot of forces working
against him there was clearly a team
Charles and clearly a team Diana
contingent and at the end of the day her
friends that are close to her say she
still loved him was the royal family
jealous of her enormous popularity
around the world
well they didn't you know she was a
different kind of royal as you know she
interacted with people she was very
engaging
she wanted her sons to have a normal
life she did she didn't have that stiff
upper lip
you know they allowed us to come shoot
at her family home and out where she's
also buried we actually got to see her
gravesite when we were there and they
don't usually open that up oh don't they
don't we were very grateful that they
allowed us to do that so you got a sense
of who she was as a little girl it's
really fascinating really excited to be
named so so again can I tell you when
the specials on yes sweetheart Charlie
can I do that course just in case you're
not at home at 8 o'clock don't miss it
too our primetime special Frances Diane
is what we're calling it her life or
death the truth tonight at 8:00 7:00
central
right here on CBS really looking forward
to that Thanks